welcome to the science Asylum I am Nick
lucid what exactly is temperature oh I
know it's just the motion of the
molecules
it's just kinetic energy sure that's the
explanation you usually get but how
accurate is that first let's review a
little in my what is energy video there
was a concept tree that looks something
like this there are all sorts of
different types of energy light is
basically just pure kinetic energy but
light doesn't have temperature sure you
might see a label like this on a box of
bulbs but that's not the temperature of
light it's just the temperature of the
metal filament that would naturally emit
that kind of light without matter the
concept of temperature doesn't even make
sense matter is everything that has mass
most of the time that's atoms made of
protons neutrons and electrons all of
those little bits have kinetic energy if
those bits are moving randomly then
that's it but if their motion has some
kind of trend then what they make up is
also moving this idea of motion extends
to every level of existence all the way
up to things we can see but how much of
that is temperature first I think we can
rule out the kinetic energy of this
walking guy that's normal-sized energy
and as he already said it's just the
motion of the molecules we're talking
about tiny things that's what we call
internal energy the energy inside things
the energy we can't see let's take the
bottom-up approach the energy of the
stuff inside protons and neutrons isn't
temperature that's just mass the energy
of protons and neutrons isn't
temperature either
that's just nuclear energy the energy
between atoms and molecules is just
chemical energy this comes down to the
kinetic energy of just the atoms and
molecules so it makes sense that we call
this thermal energy but not all of it
remember we're not including the motion
of the things these molecules make up
just the random bits it's molecules
would still have if it weren't moving so
which random bits exactly those tiny
molecules wiggle and jiggle and spin and
shift as long as none of it affects how
the normal sized object moves then
you're good but hold up a second this
big lake always has way more kinetic
energy than I do but we can still both
have the same temperature it can even be
colder and still have more kinetic
energy hmm so what's it mean for things
to be the same temperature what did you
become the voice of reason if two things
are sitting next to each other then
they'll swap energy if one thing is
than the other more energy will move to
the colder thing this will warm up the
colder thing and cool off the hotter
thing the temperatures will slowly meet
in the middle and the energy swap will
balance out analogy time Andrew Preston
wanted to know what it meant for things
to be wet anyway let's say you're
soaking wet from getting out of the
shower naturally you reach for your
towel to dry off you have extra water
and the towel has places for it to go
eventually though the towel fills up
most of those places and now it's just
giving as much water to you as you are
to it let's call that property dampness
it doesn't measure how much water is in
the towel just something more like
average water per fabric loop
likewise temperature doesn't measure the
total amount of molecular kinetic energy
it just measures the average amount of
kinetic energy per molecule and the
thing about averages is they can lose
their meaning if data is too varied so
the same thing can happen with
temperature sometimes wow this turned
into a super deep question so what's
your ideal temperature please share in
the comments - somewhere between 68 and
74 Fahrenheit and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy